das bei mir im studio ist joachim weber
russland und militärexperte am cassis
institut der universität bonn herzlich
willkommen zur später stunde ja welche
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine sind
denn wirklich nötig und würden einen
unterschied machen damit die ukraine in
der lage ist sich gegen russland zu
verteidigen ja das ist in der tat das
was wir eben schon gehört haben die so
genannten schweren waffen also panzer
und gepanzerte gefechtsfahrzeuge
artillerie raketenwerfer alle diese
sachen mit dem man ein großes sozusagen
militärisches feuerwerk entfalten kann
und auch unter schutz angriffe fahren
kann gegen einen gegner das sind alles
dinge die man braucht wenn man sich
wirklich erfolgreich im feld behaupten
will haben sie verständnis für die
zurückhaltende deutsche position ja
verständnis habe ich schon noch ein
bisschen also man kann ja wenn es um
fragen von krieg und frieden geht nicht
vorsichtig genug sein also diese haltung
halte ich grundsätzlich für richtig
andererseits haben wir alle unsere
meinung ein bisschen gewandelt denke ich
in den vergangenen wochen ich habe
anfangs auch sehr zur vorsicht gemahnt
und bin jetzt auch an dem punkt wo ich
sage wir sollten ein bisschen mutiger
werden und die ukraine in ihrem in ihrem
verzweifelten bemühen sich gegen diese
fortgesetzten russischen angriffe zu
verteidigen sie darin zu ertüchtigen
dass sie das auch tun können wenn wir
jetzt zum beispiel kampfpanzer liefern
würden kommen die denn noch rechtzeitig
und wie lange dauert das denn bis der
ukrainische soldaten auf beispielsweise
ein leopard 2 panzer geschult werden
ja da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche
meinungen dazu wie lange das dauert also
wir haben wieder viele viele wochen
verloren indem diese debatten hier
geführt werden die zu relativ wenig
ergebnissen bisher geführt haben
vielleicht sind das genau die wochen die
jetzt fehlen nicht also ich sage mal
wenn man das alles ganz beschleunigt
macht dann schafft man es vielleicht die
soldaten an diesen geräten binnen zwei
wochen auszubilden aber ob das alle
probleme löst das bleibt ein bisschen
fraglich sie müssen ja auch die
funktionierenden logistik hätten für
diese komplexen waffensystemen haben
einen ein kampfpanzer besteht aus sehr
vielen einzelteile da geht gerne was
kaputt und dem gefecht erst recht und
sie müssen ja diese ganzen ersatzteile
auch da haben die mechaniker mussten
darin geschult sein also so einfach wie
man hier das jetzt darzustellen
versuchen ist es dann auch nicht lassen
sie uns mal einen blick werfen auf die
gegenwärtige militärische situation wir
haben dazu eine karte vorbereitet es
geht um die ost ukraine den sogenannten
don't ask also das ist die erweitert die
region um lohans kontern es vielleicht
können sie mal beschreiben anhand dieser
karte welche ziele verfolgt denn die
russische offensive
ja es wäre jetzt einfacher wenn ich auf
der größeren karte zeigen könnte also es
ist so man habe es auf die kategorie war
wunderbar da kann man es leichter machen
nicht also der don was ist ja diese
region hier und das sind die teile die
die russen ja schon vorher besetzt
hatten das jetzt ein bisschen
ausgestellt haben sie wollen natürlich
den rest und möglicherweise auch noch
sehr viel mehr und die gefahr ist
natürlich dass es hier zu einer
einkesselung von ukrainischen kräften
kommen könnte es würde also heißen wenn
die russischen truppen von schalke von
unten von der krim vorstoßen und hier
diese russische ost armee eingeschlossen
würde ja das haben sie sogar schon
energisch versucht indem sie aktiv
einfach liegen gelassen haben und hier
nach südosten über ist sie um weiter
vorgestoßen sind um die kräfte hier
einzukesseln aber es gibt auch die
gefahr der der großen zange nicht wenn
sie aus diesen gebieten die sich schon
besetzt haben die das ja mario pohl auch
noch wenn sie von hier hoch stoßen und
auch um archiv so herum kommen dann
könnte es auch möglicherweise seien das
sehr große verbände der ukraine hier
eingekesselt was könnte denn die ukraine
jetzt tun um so eine einkesselung zu
verhindern ja diese gefahr ist die
ukraine natürlich auch bewusst und sie
werden alles tun um ihre flanken zu
schützen und es ist immer eine frage
dessen erkennt man die absichten des
gegners früh genug wenn also die
aufklärung der ukraine gut genug
funktioniert dass sie wissen hier kommt
der entscheidende stoß frontal oder
kommt über den linken flügel bei den
rechten flügel dann stärken man dort
natürlich ansprechen die kräfte aber das
heißt doch dass man sie anderswo wieder
abziehen muss also sie können nicht
überall gleich stark sein und das ist
ein vorteil den der angreifer nun wieder
hat weil er ja im geheimen seine kräfte
da verschieben kann wenn es die andere
seite nicht merkt und dann stößt er von
der einen stelle vor man hat es von der
anderen erwartet nicht das ist nicht
ohne risiko der eindruck der bisher
vorherrscht ist der dass der russische
angriff zumindest der auf kiew sehr
schlecht vorbereitet war haben sie den
eindruck dass die russische armee
diesmal ihre offensive besser
vorbereitet hat also ich halte die
russen schon für lernfähig sie werden
sich sicherlich sehr bemüht haben jetzt
aus ihren fehlern zu lernen das wird
hoher druck dahinter seien auch vom
präsidenten der sanitär weitergibt und
dann geht das die ganze hühnerleiter
runter bis in die truppe vor ort ich
denke sie werden ihre kräfte auf jeden
fall sehr viel stärker konzentrieren
dieses mal letztes mal haben sie völlig
displays aus allen richtungen irgendwas
zu machen versucht und wenn man alles
versucht dann scheitert man an allem
weil man nichts richtig macht das werden
sie jetzt wahrscheinlich besser machen
und sie haben natürlich nach wie vor
ungeheure feuerkraft und mehr sicherlich
auch an nachschub den sie heranführen
können als die ukraine also das steht
jetzt sicherlich spitz auf knopf für die
ich würde gemeinsam mit ihnen gern noch
einen kurzen beitrag anschauen den
ukrainischen truppen sind spektakuläre
erfolge gegen die russische armee
gelungen zb die zerstörung des kreuzes
moskau aber war das wirklich so russland
bestreitet dass das schiff von einer
rakete getroffen wurde ein kurzer blick
auf die suche nach der wahrheit im krieg
welche möglichkeiten nutzen denn sie um
zu überprüfen was wahr ist und was
gelogen in diesem krieg ja da bin ich
ein ganzes stück weit auch auf die
arbeit dieser rechercheplattform
angewiesen wie berlin kehrt zum beispiel
irgendwo muss man sich entscheiden wem
will man was glauben und da habe ich
schon den eindruck dass dort sehr
seriöse sehr an fakten orientierte
arbeit geleistet wird das ist eine
gewichtige stimme und dann kommt ein
bisschen erfahrung natürlich auch dazu
wenn man ein paar jahrzehnte kriege und
diese dinge beobachtet hat dann kriegt
man auch so ein bisschen gefühl dafür
wer verliebt und wer nicht vielleicht
weiß man zum einzelfall nicht
hundertprozentig aber man entwickelt so
einen gewissen sechs sind auch für diese
dinge mit derzeit 14 will ja in diesem
krieg sehr viele belege für russische
kriegsverbrechen und seen
vergleichsweise wenige belege über
solche der ukraine liegt das daran weil
kriegsverbrechen terror zur strategie
der russischen kriegsführung gehört oder
weil zumindest die russische führung so
etwas zulässt und nicht unterbindet oder
haben wir in diesem konflikt zu sehr
eine einseitig ukrainische brille auf
also ein bisschen wird unser blick schon
einseitig sein wir sind ja sozusagen
moralisch partei wir sind mit dem
angegriffenen wir sind ja irgendwie alle
auf seiten der ukraine weil dieses land
angegriffen wird und russland der
aggressor ist das ist in diesem fall ja
sehr klar verteilt dennoch glaube ich
verrate ich kein geheimnis wenn ich sage
in jedem krieg werden von allen seiten
kriegsverbrechen begangen
es gibt mit sicherheit auch ukrainische
kriegsverbrechen das steht für mich
außer frage auch wenn ich über deren
umfang und dergleichen nicht bescheid
weiß aber es ist schon ein unterschied
auch in der kriegführung und die ukraine
haben ja auch sozusagen keine
gelegenheit sich an zivilisten zu
vergreifen das sind ja ihre eigenen
leute dass die dass die russen das in so
großem stil tun ist natürlich
schockierend aber wenn man russische
kriegsführung kennt dann ist es so
überraschend auch wieder nicht also ich
kenne keine kriege die die russen anders
geführt hätte man möge mir einen nennen
dann kann man sich darüber unterhalten
aber wenn ich das über lange zeiträume
also nicht nur über jahrzehnte sondern
ich sogar jahrhunderte revue passieren
dass sie dann ist das die russischen
methode der kriegsführung da werden die
zivilisten nicht unbedingt geschont
herzlichen dank für diese einschätzung